[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et lundi et point de vue
revient pour une nouvelle semaine des
changes de confrontation de débats entre
deux intervenants qui ne sont pas
forcément d'accord bonsoir nicolas
baverez vous êtes économiste et
essayiste vous êtes aussi avocat
chroniqueur au figaro selon réjouissons
on vous retrouve chaque lundi dans les
pages du figaro quotidien et sur le site
internet quelques heures plus tôt votre
dernier livre l'alertent démocratique a
été publié aux édition de l'observatoire
et puis nous accueillons avec joie
alexandre ii vecchio bonsoir à défendre
vous êtes le responsable des pages
débats du figaro magazine qui est un
poste important
les essais en charge du figaro boxe on
vous retrouve aussi sur lci vous avez
rejoint l'équipe de chroniqueurs de deux
familles dont on se réjouit est votre
dernier livre recomposition
le nouveau monde populiste a été publié
aux éditions du cerf on va commencer si
vous le voulez bien par parler d'un
nouveau délit écocide échos comme
écologie et seed com qui tue c'est le
suffixe bien connu il ya aussi des
pesticides des homicides et donc le
gouvernement a annoncé la création
prochaine d'un délit d' écocide pour
punir les atteintes contre
l'environnement
écoutez ce qu'en disait ce matin sur
france info barbara pompiers
la ministre de la transition écologique
était euphorique et le glaive de la
justice qui va s'abattre
enfin surtout les bandits
l'environnement avec eric dupond-moretti
on a mis en place et on va le faire
voter dans la loi la semaine prochaine
un grand délit qui va permettre de faire
payer tout ce qu'ils soient sans le
faire exprès soit parce qu'ils l'ont
voulu parce qu'ils l'ont fait exprès
porte des atteintes à l'environnement ce
sera un délit transversale si jamais on
abîme l'environnement eh bien on sera
condamné m ba vrai qu'est ce que
l'avocat que vous êtes france de cette
initiative
écoutez gens pensent plutôt du mal parce
qu'on a l'impression qu'il n'existe pas
de droit de l'environnement
à entendre la ministre or aujourd'hui
forte heureusement il ya un droit de
l'environnement et il ya déjà tout un
arsenal de mesures répressives
fort heureusement est d'ailleurs en plus
d'avoir un arsenal
on a des condamnations et on a déjà en
revanche un carcan ce qu'il faut un
équilibre entre évidemment la protection
de l'environnement mais le fait de
pouvoir travailler entreprendre et
notamment d'avoir une industrie avec le
principe de précaution c'était déjà
compliqué je dois dire que si ce délit
de déco sida lors d'autant qu'on annonce
par ailleurs qui devrait être complété
par une disposition réprimant la mise en
danger de l'environnement et là je crois
que très franchement je ne vois pas qui
va pouvoir continuer à faire de
l'industrie en france dans un contexte
pareil
la deuxième remarque c'est que tout ça
nous vient de la convention citoyenne
qui n'avait citoyenne de peine pour le
climat ils étaient réunis pendant le
long mois on s'en souvient la kinase
économique et le citoyenne que de que le
nom et si vous voulez tout cette espèce
de logorrhée évite de traiter le vrai
problème le vrai problème
tous les économistes savent que la seule
vraie réponse en matière d'environnement
c'est le prix du carbone et donc il faut
faire fonctionner le marché du carbone
avec un prix qui passe à 50 euros en
2025 à 100 euros en 2030
c'est ce que retient total pour sa
planification et au lieu de faire ça
parce que le gouvernement par sa
maladresse a créé avec la tentative de
taxe carbone
la révolte des gilet jaune la convention
citoyenne elle s'est occupée de tout
sauf des deux sujets qui compte c'est à
dire l'énergie nucléaire et puis le prix
du carbone et dont on multiplie toute
une série de mesures qui sont
liberticides qui sont attentatoires
puisqu'on envisageait aussi je vous le
rappelle 2
réviser la constitution pour expliquer
que les droits de l'homme était
désormais subordonnée au droit de
l'environnement et est donc très
franchement c'est vraiment de la
communication et je pense que ça dessert
y compris la protection de
l'environnement
il faut aujourd'hui c'est un la
protection de l'environnement c'est très
sérieux mais c'est parce que c'est
sérieux qu'il faut le faire de manière
efficace raisonnée et performante et on
sait que la réponse à tout ça c'est le
prix du carbone parce que c'est la
manière le signal du prix c'est ce qui
fait rentrer le la protection de
l'environnement dans chaque camp des
actes doc et chacune des fonctions
économiques qu'on soit épargnants
investisseurs consommateurs producteurs
tout le monde doit en tenir compte et au
lieu de faire ça on va simplement faire
une nouvelle mesure franco française qui
sera dévastatrice pour notre économie
et dernière chose quand même voyez
toutes ces mesures de la convention
citoyenne c'est quand même très
intéressant il n'y a pas une évaluation
voyez pop
on parle là de de ce délit d' écocide
est ce qu'on peut dire qu'on voit est ce
que quelqu'un s'est donné la peine de
regarder le coût en termes économiques
et sociaux est ce que ça permet
d'économiser comme émissions de carbone
ou de gaz à effet de serre mais personne
n'a fait d'évaluation
en revanche en termes de gains
politiques je pense qu'il ya dû y avoir
des évaluations je suis sûr que notre
sujet sur les sondages on est sûrement
largement en avance sur les évaluations
socio-économiques comme chaque jour
évidemment vous réagissez
sur twitter sur lefigaro.fr sur youtube
aussi c'est le cas de gascon qui nous
dit employer le suffixe side en parlant
des causses idée complètement hystérique
on dirait que l'on parle d'un meurtre
alors on parle pas d'un meurtre cher
gascon en a fait il parlait d'un crime
et puis finalement ça a été requalifiés
en délits dans le projet du gouvernement
nicole sur lefigaro.fr est aussi
critique que vous nicolas baverez sur la
convention citoyenne puisqu'elle estime
que ça a été une escroquerie
et puis christophe qui nous pose la
question le gouvernement à fermer une
centrale nucléaire ce qui oblige à
ouvrir des centrales à charbon
le gouvernement sera-t-il puni descossy
point d'interrogation alors ce qui est
vrai cher christophe c'est que on a
effectivement fermer fessenheim
il ya des centrales thermiques qui
rouvre mais en france elle ne sont elles
ne sont pas à charbon mais en orange
c'est certain qu'elle peut le plus que
le nucléaire
alexandre de vie qu'est ce que vous êtes
aussi sévère que votre co débatteurs oui
quand vous êtes vous êtes jeune
profitez-en savions donc vous devriez
vous préoccuper de l'avenir de la
planète mais je suis pas sûr que ça
résoudra le moindre problème là où mon
camarade a raison c'est quand il dit
qu'on n'a pas évalué la mesure je pense
pas que ça va
voilà réduire les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre ou que ça va préserver la
planète d'une quelconque façon on voit
bien qu'il ya un an c'est un gadget qui
a un calcul effectivement politique je
suis pas sûr d'ailleurs en fait que
emmanuel mâcon veuille spécialement
récupérer les voix des écolos je me
demande s'ils laissaient pas de les
faire monter juste assez pour diviser la
gauche puisqu'il a plutôt intérêt à
avoir plusieurs candidats de gauche
c'est une mesure gadget qui déplaira pas
forcément à l'électorat de droite et du
coup voilà on voit le calcul politique
et puis il faut tout simplement occuper
barbara pompili qu'elle est un bilan est
donc c'est plus facile de mettre des
choses comme ça dans la loi que de
transformer réellement notre modèle
notre modèle économique
sociale etc mais ces gadgets mais c'est
tout de même dangereux
je pense que c'est particulièrement
floues en termes de droit moi je ne sais
pas ce que ça recouvre
est ce que si je fais pas le tri
sélectif je suis coupable de déco sied
de l'internaute avait pas tort sur la
responsabilité des états après tout
telle ou telle association pourra porter
plainte contre l'état si haut des
centrales thermiques
est-ce que ça concerne les grandes
catastrophes naturelles type marée noire
ou les personnes qui croque or c'est un
pas naturel mais les grandes
catastrophes industrielles et écologique
ou la personne qui va couper un arbre
j'en sais rien mais c'est puni quand
même entre 3 ans et 10 ans de de prison
donc ça laisse la possibilité à toutes
les interprétations en termes de droit
et enfin sur le plan sémantique le terme
et écocide pose tout de même problème là
encore d'un internaute qui disait on se
demande si on a l'impression qu'on parle
d'un meurtre effectivement il ya une
forme de personnification de la nature
dans ce terme-là et s'il faut respecter
la nature je pense que l'homme doit être
humble par rapport à la nature et il
doit pouvoir éviter de toujours vouloir
l'a dominé de manière inconséquente mais
de là à faire de la nature une personne
ça rime d'une certaine manière on pense
immédiatement à génocide et donc je
trouve ça assez inquiétant en plus je
pense que les militants qui ont tendance
à faire finalement de la nature un homme
une personne ont parfois tendance à à
détester les êtres humains donc c'est
quand même ouvrir une boîte de pandore
pour pour un gain pour un calcul
électoral un peu un peu cynique les
internautes s'en sont moins affirmatifs
que vous dans l'eure
point de vue en tout cas si l'on en
croit ce petit questionnaire auquel vous
êtes invités à répondre
êtes vous favorable à l'instauration
d'un délit d' écocide et c'est non mais
à 52% donc c'est moins moins tranchée
que pour vous et puis je vous propose
ces deux commentaires celui de babineau
sur lefigaro.fr
on observe la progression constante du
vote écolo l'écocide et principalement
de l'affichage et christophe sur
lefigaro.fr avec 120 % dette
on a peut-être d'autres priorités non
mais peut-être nicolas baverez que si on
même si c'est un peu de la communication
ci ont créé ce nouveau délit c'est parce
que on n'a pas été suffisamment sévères
jusqu'à présent avec ce genre de 2,2
des lits et puis aussi parce que les
français sont choqués de voir que par
exemple même si c'est au brésil est loin
de chez nous on peut impunément détruire
d'aider des millions d'hectares de
forêts cette prise de conscience d'aller
salutaire quand maintenant mais la prise
de conscience elle est évidemment bonne
et par ailleurs personne ne discute
qu'avec le avec le numérique la
transition écologique soit le plus grand
défi des années qui viennent mais je le
répète pour prenons l'exemple du brésil
d'abord il faut pas croire que en france
à juste titre on critique beaucoup
l'extra territorialité des lois
américaines
mais il faut pas croire qu'avec les lois
françaises on va régler les problèmes de
l'amazonie on peut les appliquer en
guyane ça oui c'est un territoire
français mais en revanche expliqué qu'on
va faire les lois pour les brésiliens
ça me paraît quand même bizarre en
revanche ce qu'on peut faire c'est se
battre notamment si avec à joe biden les
états unis reviennent dans l'accord de
paris là on peut avoir des normes
internationales essayer de faire
progresser cette défense de
l'environnement aussi au plan
international mais la pire manière de
faire de l'écologie c'est ce qu'on fait
en france c'est à dire de ne pas faire
les dispositions économiques qu'on sait
être efficace pour faire des
dispositions d'affichage et notamment
des dispositions pénales parce que c'est
le paradoxe de ce pays où on a un mépris
complet pour l'état de droit mais on
pénalise tous et ils ont abouti à on
aboutit à des catastrophes regarder
l'état aujourd'hui où en est l'état il a
voulu tout pénalisé et c'est maintenant
ils se retrouvent avec tous les
dirigeants qui se mute multiples
procédures pour la crise sanitaire et du
coup on recourt au conseil de défense
pour s'occuper de la crise de sanitas
critique est une monstruosité
parce que c'est pas fait eux c'est pas
du tout faits pour ça donc si vous
voulez à chaque fois ce type de choses
se retourne contre eux c'est ses
promoteurs
donc aujourd'hui si on veut faire de la
lutte efficace contre l'environnement on
est bien d'accord que l'agression contre
la pollution et pour protéger
l'environnement vous avez parfaitement
raison
le but c'est d'introduire sa dans la
logique de fonctionnement du capitalisme
parce que c'est ça la mécanique la plus
puissante donc d'obliger tous les
opérateurs mais aussi les investisseurs
les boursiers les à prendre en compte
cette dimension et pour ça on sait que
le seul mécanique efficace c'est le sait
le prix du carbone est évidemment la
mise en place d'une taxe carbone aux
frontières
parce que là pour le coup il faut éviter
une rupture de concurrence avec les avec
les concurrents étrangers des
entreprises européennes
c'est pour ça si vous voulez que cette
gesticulation est non seulement inutile
mais qu'elle est dangereuse parce que ça
se retournera mécaniquement contre la
protection de l'environnement
tout comme la multiplication des lois
pénales dans le domaine politique ont
abouti à un état qui est à la fois
paralysé et impuissants face aux crises
comme on l'a vu récemment d'autres
points de vue celui de daisy sur youtube
qui elle est plutôt favorable considère
que c'est une bonne chose d'instaurer le
délit d' écocide mais que le mieux
serait de ne pas en arriver là
grâce à de la pédagogie et à des aides
financières
nicole qui souhaiteraient qu'on punisse
déjà les dépôts sauvages de déchets un
peu partout ça existe déjà c'est un
délit qui est déjà constitué alexandre
ii vecchio nicolas baverez disait c'est
pas avec un des leades écocide en france
qu'on va empêcher
ball sonar au brésil 2-2
[Musique]
m d'accélérer la déforestation mais ça
c'est un peu l'état d'esprit français
c'est la même chose que la taxe carbone
on en est l'un des pays au monde qui
sommes le moins émetteurs de co2 et
pourtant on se punit nous mêmes comme
s'il fallait prendre le poids de la
faute de la planète sur nos épaules
oui c'est un gadget effectivement on l'a
vu le sondage la plupart des gens son
tour parce que quand on dit ça comme ça
ça c'est bien on va punir les méchants
qui abîment l'environnement donc ça peut
paraître plein de bons sentiments mais
l'enfer est tout de même pas avait de
bonnes intentions sur hubble sauna ou
moi je crois malgré tous ces militants
là qui ont fait aboutir le délit d co
sida en france travaillent aussi à
l'international
plusieurs tentatives pour mettre ce
crémant parce que dans un traité parce
que là pour le coup ce serait ce serait
un crime
je suis pas sûr que ce soit souhaitable
et qu'il faille déclencher une guerre
avec bel sonar ou sur la masse volumique
parce que si on va jusqu'au bout de la
logique c'est une espèce de gouvernement
mondial qui ensuite tordrait le bras aux
souverainetés nationales et moi je vois
là je suis pas forcément pour pour ce
schéma là mais après encore une fois
quand je disais il ya 52 % des français
qui sont pour moi pensons qu'ils sont en
train de nous suivre
ils sont le meilleur de la foulée
effectivement il faut qu'on préserve au
mieux la nature et peut-être il faut
être plus sévère avec les gens qui
déposent des produits chimiques dans les
fleuves des choses comme ça où il faut
être impitoyable
est-ce que sa nécessité d'en passer par
ce délit grande éloquence grandiloquent
déco side dont on ne sait pas
effectivement très précisément ce qu'ils
décident des défis nés et qui pourrait
avoir effectivement des des effets
inverses par la suite y compris par pour
ses promoteurs
je ne crois pas ce que vous direz c'est
que ceux qui jettent des produits
chimiques nocifs lévis porte
heureusement fort heureusement il ya des
dispositions buy est illégale a droit de
l'environnement ont pour elles
pourraient durcir
voilà on n'est pas en étant plus
prestigieux de rester dans le registre
du droit et de la justice
le procès de nicolas sarkozy dans l'
affaire dite des écoutes s'est ouvert
brièvement ce matin devant le tribunal
correctionnel de paris avant d'être
suspendues jusqu'à jeudi pour cause de
contrôle de santé d'un des protagonistes
de la faire c'est donc l'un des volets 1
judiciaire contre nicolas sarkozy l'
affaire dite des écoutes il ya aussi la
ferdi du financement libyen on se
souvient que le principal accusateur de
l'ex-président est attaquée dean est
revenu sur ses déclarations
tout ceci fait que certains considèrent
qu' il ya une sorte d'acharnement
judiciaire contre nicolas sarkozy
c'est la vie ça ne vous surprendra
peut-être pas de claude guéant l'ancien
secrétaire général de l'elysée lui il
est à fond derrière son ancien patron
dans cette affaire-là show qui me semble
grave comme dans d'autres demeurant cia
qui a clairement un acharnement une
volonté d'humilier qui se traduit que ce
soit voulu ou pas voulu par une
intervention dans le domaine politique
et c'est un une évolution de la justice
sur laquelle les français je crois sont
légitimement en droit de s'interroger
alors c'est aux juges d'en décider mais
est-ce que vous avez une intime
conviction alexandre ii vecchio dans
cette affaire est ce que la justice et
on travaille normalement elle en fait un
peu trop
non j'ai l'intimé conviction qu'il ya un
acharnement je suis pas spécialement
sarkozyste mais on voit bien que dans le
dossier takieddine était vide
il a retiré son témoignage pouces a été
partie juste avant la volée mais je
tiens parce que les écoutes ont été
cette affaire sur un dossier qui lui
même ne tient pas debout un dossier qui
a été lancé par mediapart avait qu'un
faux documents au scanner il a été
prouvé qu'ils étaient scanner qui
reposait plus que sur le témoignage de
ziad takieddine qui est quand même cas
en fuite et qui est pas un témoignage
extrêmement friable sur ce il ya
effectivement cette affaire bismuth où
les juges ont écouté nicolas sarkozy et
son avocat ce qui n'est pas légal
et du coup ils ont il ya une affaire
dans la sphère parce que d'après les
écoutes nicolas sarkozy aurait tenté de
voir de corrompre un magistrat pour
obtenir un non lieu justement dans la
sphère takieddine au beau fixe
extrêmement compliqué mais c'est traduit
effectivement moi je suis contre le
gouvernement des juges et et les juges
ne se contente plus depuis longtemps de
dire le droit mais défendre je crois une
idéologie dont le voit dans plusieurs
domaines mais on l'a vu avec le la
sphère du mur des cons ou il y avait des
personnalités de droite qui étaient
peints de l'est mais aussi des familles
de victimes de meurtres de viols etc qui
avait le tort de trouver que la justice
n'était pas forcément assez sévères donc
là on voit une justice de plus en plus
idéologique et qui piétine le pouvoir le
pouvoir politique dès qu'elle le peut on
l'a vu avec nicolas sarkozy on a vu
aussi d'une certaine matière dans la
sphère fillon la justice est intervenue
en pleine campagne présidentielle et à
changer le cours de l'élection
donc je crois que ce n'est pas
souhaitable et qu'il aimait
le pouvoir judiciaire doit rester à sa
place c'est à dire de dire les lois qui
sont votées par l'exécutif on la sent
l'odieux aussi en verve hier dans un
instant dans l'intervention judiciaire
dans la crise sanitaire actuelle vous il
faisait allusion il ya quelques minutes
nicolas baverez mais vous avez vous eu
un avis sur sur cette affaire sarkozy
vous trouvez que c'est trop que écouter
les attentions des magistrats je ne les
connais pas mais plutôt que de dire
qu'on a une justice politique je crois
que ce qui est très préoccupant c'est
qu'on a une justice qui fonctionne hors
de l'état de droit
c'est ça qui est très choquant c'est
vrai que d'abord la multiplication des
procédures contre nicolas sarkozy et le
fait toujours des mêmes magistrats et
qu'on a une infinité myriade de
procédure mais qu'on retrouve toujours
les mêmes donc ça c'est déjà quand même
étonnant mais surtout ce qui est
notamment le juge d'instruction
tournaire qui est qu'elle pivot toutes
ces affaires effectivement qui était
d'ailleurs aussi le pivot de la sphère
fillon mais ce qui est extrêmement
préoccupant c'est ce qui a été rappelé
c'est à dire que toutes ces affaires
sont montés d'abord sur des enquêtes
préliminaires avec une situation qui est
extrêmement choquant et qui nous met
quand même
retour à l'ancien régime avant la
déclaration des droits de l'homme
puisqu'on a des magistrats qui pendant
des années peuvent enquêter sur vous
sans même que vous soyez informés sans
aucun moyen de vous défendre vous n'avez
pas accès au dossier sauf si finalement
ensuite on bascule dans une procédure
avec instruction et pendant des années
on peut vous écoutez ce qui a été fait
puisque en l'occurrence on a des
dizaines d'avocats mais aussi nombreux
journalistes qui ont été écoutés pendant
des années et coûter localiser pendant
des années mais enfin ccc poutinien
personne ne peut faire ça aux états unis
un complément personne ne peut faire ça
aux états unis personne ne peut faire ça
au royaume-uni personne ne peut faire ça
en allemagne 20 c'est ahurissant
et là effectivement et paradoxe quand
même de ce procès c'est que il repose
sur une affaire bettencourt dans
laquelle nicolas sarkozy a eu un non
lieu
donc théoriquement l'a fait et ça repose
sur des écoutes qui sont des écoutes
comme il a été dit qu'ils sont entre un
client et son avocat et qui sont
fondamentalement de fait en dehors du en
dehors du droit
donc moi ce qui me préoccupe dans la
justice aujourd'hui c'est exactement ça
c'est à dire que non seulement ces de
montesquieu qui disait que le juge
devait être la bouche de la loi donc non
seulement aujourd'hui les magistrats
prétendent faire les lois mais il se
refuse à appliquer les lois qui existent
et notamment les lois les plus
fondamentales qui sont les lois qui
garantissent les libertés des citoyens
et ça c'est une situation qui est
effectivement extrêmement préoccupante
mais alors on peut dire derrière que
c'est vrai que la justice n'est qu'une
simple autorités ce qui est sûrement
dans la vème république et pas un
pouvoir c'est sûrement une faute
il est vrai que l est dans la misère
mais d'ailleurs les magistrats en sont
en partie responsables parce qu'à force
d'avoir voulu gérer l'informatique et
tout ce genre de trucs
ben ça ne marche tout simplement pas on
l'a vu ce qui est quand même un scandale
n'a encore parce que les mêmes qui
feront pendant trois mois pendant le
confinement c'est quand même le seul la
seule démocratie où pendant trois mois
les tribunaux ont fermé parce que les
greffes non ça c'est du vécu d'avocats
sauf la justice administrative qui a
plutôt mieux marcher mais si vous voulez
le fait que les greffiers n'est pas de
d'ordinateurs portables bon et donc on
ferait mieux de s'occuper de ça et
dernier mot pendant qu'on utilise des
centaines de policiers à faire tout ça
il s'occupa de s'occuper de la lutte
antiterroriste alors nos internautes
sont globalement d'accord avec vous un
sur twitter avec la tenue du procès
sarkozy sur les écoutes trouvez vous que
la justice est trop politique
et la réponse est oui à 69% donc on est
dans du temps du 2/3 1/3 réflexion de
chardons bleus sur lefigaro.fr on juge
des pseudos intentions tout ça est très
flou christophe fait remarquer comme
vous que on développe de gros moyens
pour ce genre d'affaires alors que le
budget de la justice est trop serré et
puis à une requête qui vous est adressée
cher alexandre de vécu à l'aide françois
sur le site du figaro que monsieur
devait que ne range pas tous les
magistrats dans le même tiroir quand il
faut car ils font un métier difficile
jusqu'au bout il conviendra évidemment
on peut tous les magistrats il faut il
faut ranger personnes dans le col et
d'étiquettes à personne mais il ya à mon
avis une dérive de la justice j'ai un
point de nuances avec nicolas baverez
quand il dit en france la justice n'ait
aucune autorité est pas un pouvoir et
c'est un temps effectivement
dans la constitution de la vème
république le général de gaulle avait
fait en sorte que la justice soit
simplement une autorité
je crois plus que c'est le cas
aujourd'hui je crois qu'elle s'est bien
rattrapé et quand on est con on en a la
preuve est qu elle elle veut en montrer
aux pouvoirs politiques et ça s'inscrit
dans une dans une évolution qui est
d'ailleurs occidentale et pas seulement
et pas seulement française avec des
magistrats qui avec la multiplication
des juridictions détacher des états avec
qui juge en fonction de droits de
l'homme abstrait je pense à la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme dont la
juridiction s'applique à tous les états
membres
et ça je pense que c'est une dérive
dérive importante c'est un autre sujet
plus léger les nombreux liens avec la
pour en revenir à l'actualité brûlante
est ce que dans le contexte de la crise
sanitaire on sait que la cour de justice
de la république a ouvert des procédures
contre les ministres mais aussi il y en
a contre les hauts fonctionnaires alors
ce ne sont pas des mises en examen même
pas les enquêtes préliminaires mais on
parle de de mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui d'homicide involontaire
la justice et est vigilante et c'est
normal vous trouvez qu'elle n'est pas à
sa place
las il faudrait voir dossier par dossier
mais c'est un principe ça vous gêne pas
quelle quelle qu'elle soit active
pendant la crise elle-même le fait
qu'elle soit actif pendant la crise elle
même si j'allais venir je trouve ça gêne
on puisque ça a un impact manifeste sur
la gestion de la crise on voit bien que
les politiques sont terrorisés à l'idée
de devoir rendre des comptes à la
justice et que ça paralyse l'action du
gouvernement dans des circonstances
exceptionnelles où il faut agir vite
parfois sans doute s'extraire de
certaines procédures et ça effectivement
avec l'épée de damoclès de la justice ça
rend tout cela beaucoup plus compliqué
c'est vrai que les décisions politiques
qui sont prises pendant cette crise
devrait relever du politique et le
suffrage universel devrait être d'une
certaine manière le le jeu des pelles et
les français jugeront si cette crise a
été bien gérée ou pas c'était pas un
juge de le faire alors deux choses très
vite sur l'europe il faut être me dirai
pas ce que l'europe c'est précisément
plutôt un garde-fou aujourd'hui la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme c'est
une des instances ou par rapport aux
dérives ou aux débordements de
la justice française et notamment ses
dérives en dehors du droit c'est là
qu'on a eu des sanctions
donc de fait elle a plutôt un rôle
positif sur la crise sanitaire
c'est l'article 15 de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen qui dit
que tout responsable public ou
administratif doit rendre compte de son
administration et donc il n'y a pas que
le suffrage universel
il faut qu'ils aient la justice et c'est
tout à fait normal mais évidemment la
justice ne doit pas interférer avec la
gestion de crise c'est comme si on
s'était amusé en 14-18 affaire a
commencé à faire passer en jugement les
responsables et on a vu que quand même
un exemple célèbre je vous rappelle sur
la deuxième guerre mondiale avec le
procès de riom
on a vu à quel point la justice pouvait
être éminemment sage raisonnable et bien
entendu quand on s'amusait à
l'instrumentaliser en cas de catastrophe
nationale pour commencer à les juger les
responsables politiques ou militaires
donc de fait le feu la justice ne doit
pas agir en même temps que les
responsables exécutifs qui s'occupe de
la crise et ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
est tout à fait déraisonnable et là
encore c'est une particularité française
si vous regardez ailleurs dans le monde
démocratique on n'a pas du tout du tout
ce genre de ce genre de choses la
défiance est sans doute moins grandes
mais surtout on a des états de droit qui
fonctionne donc
la justice ne fait ce qu'elle ne devrait
pas faire et ne fait pas ce qu'elle
devrait faire mais ça prouve au moins qu
elle ait pas si politisée que ça allait
sans doute vécu puisque s'attaque pas
seulement un nicolas sarkozy ou françois
fillon mais aussi à l'action du
gouvernement actuel non mais je pense
que plus que l'hostilité envers une
couleur politique précise même si pour
le mur dès qu'on y avait spécifiquement
des personnes de droite plus que c'est
l'un des cas la magie c'est assez à
gauche plus que cela il ya une volonté
on le disait tout à l'heure de faire la
loi en or la justice est là pour pour
exécuter les lois qui sont crespin pour
rendre la justice en fonction des lois
qui sont votées au parlement elle a
tendance à empiéter sur le pouvoir de
l'exécutif qui est finalement le
l'expression delà de la volonté du
peuple donc c'est là où il ya une dérive
il ya une volonté de faire la morale il
ya aussi une volonté je crois quand je
parle de justice idéologique c'est de
frapper peut-être plus fort ce qu'elle
estime être les puissants or je crois
qu'on doit rendre la justice
de la même façon pour les plus humbles
et les plus puissants le droit ne dit
pas des fins loi est une loi et d'un mot
je rappelle que près de nous il ya un
pays où les magistrats ont entrepris une
guerre à la classe et au système
politique et ce pays c'est l'italie
voilà on a vu le résultat de fait la
classe politique traditionnelle a
disparu et on s'est retrouvé à la place
avec d'abord s'il est ouvert jusqu'au
nié ensuite les populisme de droite et
de gauche avec la lia d'un côté fratelli
d'italia et puis de l'autre côté beppe
grillo et le mouvement 5 étoiles donc
c'est très bien de
de vouloir détruire les systèmes
politiques et les classe politique est
comme gelée dit il est parfaitement
normal que les responsables les
dirigeants politiques rendent compte de
leur administration
mais le fait de vouloir détruire un
système politique pour des raisons
effectivement de principe ça il n'y a
pas d'exemple dans les démocraties que
ce soit bien terminé
merci beaucoup à tous les deux merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis point de vue
est terminé pour ce soir mais on se
retrouvera demain à la même heure et au
même endroit
merci beaucoup
[Musique]